hello everybody welcome to another
Python mathematics and finance
indicators tutorial video in this video
we're going to be talking about Elder
force index in the next couple videos
we'll be talking about it
so what is the other force index the
idea of it is to measure directional
intensity yeah it's gonna oscillate
above and below the zero line and
basically the idea of it is to consider
changes in price and volume obviously
for the intensity part that's where you
know volume is coming in so in the price
change times you know how much volume
has come through that gives you a
directional intensity the calculation of
e fi is going to be pretty close to what
I just said it's going to be the current
close minus the previous close so what's
the actual price difference here times
the volume that's it
then you're gonna have like generally an
EMA applied to that line so you know
usually like a 14 period EMA is used but
you can use anything you want you can
use a two period EMA or even I got one
period you know you want to be crazy
about it so anyway so that's the other
force index now what I'd like to do is
show you guys an example so let me bring
up our charting application here so
let's plot up Apple for example and so
here's an elder force index for Apple as
you can see it is pretty closely
mimicking volume like right you had a
huge spike in volume so notably it goes
like way down and it comes back up again
another huge spike in volume it goes
down again and here there's a spike in
volume and a spike in the Eldar force
index and so on and then it goes down
again so obviously you can see that this
is the 14 so what if we like lowered
that to like maybe more like a 15 or I
mean a 5 for Apple so let's let me do
that real quick so now I lowered it to a
5 for apples let's bring up Apple again
with mount five and so now you can see
it's a lot more of a reactive line so
I'm gonna pull it over here and now like
if we zoomed into like a specific area
we could look at this one specifically
we can see how it's just very very
reactive much more so than the other one
was pretty late zoom into like maybe
this spot as well right so it's really
it's it's pretty much right on like here
and stuff because there's very little
change here so what's nice about is when
it's above the zero mark right that's
measuring the intensity of rising so
what happens is when it starts you know
slowing and its rise you'll see that the
EFI many times it's actually gonna start
its decline prior the price starting its
decline so that's kind of where it can
become very useful at the same time you
can also plot possibly although this
says EFI fourteen sorry I forgot to
change the label for it this is indeed
in EFI five but anyway yeah you can use
different different moving averages
right and and you can get kind of a
single signal line going on a single
line anyway so that's your EFI so in the
next video what we're gonna be doing is
actually programming the EFI into Python
and then in the next video actually
chart it up in a charting application
like this actually it's this identical
charting application so uh-huh anyway
that sounds interesting to you guys stay
tuned to the next video as always thanks
for watching